When you study TOEFL,...
...which is an exam for students...
...who want to study in an English-speaking country,...
...you have probably come across a place called Yellowstone National Park...
...in many of the reading passages.
Set up in 1872, and spreading across Wyoming, Montana and Idaho,...
...it is America's first national park.
There is a multitude of things to see.
Apart from 10,000 thermal features like geysers, hot springs and mud pools,...
...you can see wild animals like coyotes, wolves, grizzly bears, bison and elk.
Only six of the geysers erupt predictably 100 feet or higher at intervals of 45 to 90 minutes.
The most famous is Old Faithful.
Taking the Grand Loop Road, you can watch the wildlife and enjoy the roadside picnic areas.
If you are feeling active, there are many miles of hiking trails...
...with over 290 waterfalls, nine visitor centers and numerous campsites.